[Applaudissements]
avez-vous déjà entendu parler d'un gars nommé
pacificateur
non c'est un tueur entraîné
nous avons des problèmes avec ce maniaque
allez qu'attendez-vous pour
cette chose mieux pas de la merde là-bas
ouais je vais forcer un mec aigle
sans voler  son âme
hé papa
ça a été une sorte de but difficile d'un
papa quotidien tu ne dis pas que
quelqu'un m'a tiré dessus un immeuble est tombé sur moi
tu as laissé quelqu'un te tirer dessus c'est comme si je l'avais
invité à venir me tirer dessus papa
pathétique
je pensais que tu étais dedans  prison à vie je
travaille pour le
bureau de poste du gouvernement pensez-vous qu'ils me laisseraient
sortir de prison pour livrer du courrier je ne
sais pas que c'était le premier emploi gouvernemental auquel je
pouvais penser j'ai tué des gens pour lui d'
accord
ce groupe de travail ne le fait pas  t existe officiellement ce
qui nous laisse seuls nous appelons nos
cibles des papillons ils sont une
menace sérieuse pour la sécurité des citoyens américains
il se passe quelque chose de bizarre vous
pensez que moi et le justicier sommes trop stupides pour
remarquer hé tout le monde lequel est moi et
lequel va bien  tu es h  alf
right but you score 50 of the test at
school qu'est-ce que tu as l'
école n'était pas mon sac c'est pour les idiots
ce gars est un clown mais il y a quelque chose en
lui qui est
triste c'est ta cible en vue le pacificateur
pourrait les sortir même les enfants oui
terminez-les immédiatement
prenez les chaussettes
il m'a dit de tuer des enfants il n'a pas dit
pourquoi
parce qu'en ce moment le monde a besoin du
fils de [ __ ] tu es le seul que j'ai
je pensais que tu aimais la paix peu importe le
nombre d'hommes femmes et enfants  tu avais besoin
de tuer pour l'obtenir
je ne sais pas je pense que j'ai des sentiments à
propos de
certaines
choses
se comparer à un chode
n'est pas une mauvaise façon ton père n'est pas un homme bon
il fait toujours partie de la famille mon conseil coupez-le
avec l'introspection l'esprit est un repaire
de scorpions qu'il vaut mieux laisser courir de
pas vers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas
deux secousses et  costumes et quelques
rejets,
c'est comme une vraie équipe là-bas  e
yo qu'est-ce que c'est que c'est une grenade
attachée à un obus de char russe pourquoi pas
juste la grenade explose comme
deux personnes combien de personnes ça
explose je ne sais pas je l'ai inventé ce
matin quoi
[Musique]
mange la paix  [ __ ]
toi